as u.s troops prepare to complete their
withdrawal from afghanistan there's a
grim new warning about the taliban
advance one u.s official tells cbs news
that intelligence estimates predict the
afghan government could collapse in as
little as 90 days charlie dagetta was in
afghanistan on an extended reporting
trip just a few weeks ago charlie good
morning how serious are these latest
setbacks
good morning when i spoke with general
scott miller on that trip who was then
in charge of u.s and nato forces i asked
him what his biggest concern for
afghanistan was and he told me the
provincial capitals falling one after
another and in the past week that's
exactly what's happened in scenes
reminiscent of the isis rampage
throughout northern iraq and syria
taliban militants overrunning town after
town capturing equipment as they go
for 20 years america and its allies have
been supplying and training the afghan
military and they're collapsing within a
matter of days but the taliban have
become battle-hardened disciplined
warriors and they've had these cities
surrounded for weeks and even though
afghan forces outnumber the taliban by
at least six to one afghan commandos are
about the only serious fighting force
but they're stretch way too thin with
u.s air power all but gone the afghan
air force is now made up of a small
number of fixed-wing aircraft and
helicopters and they usually arrive long
after the fight is over now the white
house is hoping that the taliban's
desire for international legitimacy
might curb the worst abuses but the
taliban have shown zero interest in a
diplomatic solution
charlie hard to forget what you just
said there decades in order to take that
those cities and just days for them to
fall thank you